the Chris Sims top 5 receiver prospects
for the draft which begins three weeks
from today on Wednesday we spent a lot
of time talking about the number one
prospect CD Lam from Oklahoma and the
guy who didn't make a top 5 jerry judy
from alabama let's start with Justin
Jefferson today number 2 on the rankings
and what separates him crisp from all
the guys that you have ranked behind him
well right Justin Jefferson Mike he's
he's a similar to like a Mike Thomas
type guy you know that's where I would
say in fact I would say he's actually a
better athletic specimen than Michael
Thomas was coming out of Ohio State now
not quite as big but played a similar
role as Michael Thomas did for the
Saints in the LSU jobber Oh Joe Brady
offense which was wait for it yes the
Saints offense so he played that same a
similar role but yet he wins on the
outside a lot too now first off I would
say he's one of the best route runners
in the draft all right so that's the
first thing he's fearless over the
middle he can make place after the catch
as you could see right here he can
double moves beat you down field with
size and speed Mike anytime I see a
50/50 ball
Justin Jefferson catches it it doesn't
matter you're seeing it right here every
time and he's doing everything so you
know to me again this is and I don't
want to knock Jerry Judy who I like but
this is the better version of Jerry Judy
this is the guy everybody expect from
Jerry Judy and I'm just trying to say no
Justin Jeffersons is this guy you know
his ability to do all of those things
that we just talked about it just has
such great value in the NFL so I think
ultimately he's going to be a slot
receiver cuz he's fearless over the
middle he could play through contact
he's got great play strength he can
break tackles you know he could turn the
ball off the sideline and make highlight
type plays he really has everything and
to me he's one of the safest picks of
the draft I think he's kind of a
can't-miss prospect I don't see I think
it's his his floor is very high as they
say in the draft world right Mike and
here's the thing when you prese Justin
Jefferson and when we show highlights
like that man it starts me it starts
making me wonder how
of Jo burrows rise I hear you Jo burrows
draft stock is influenced by the fact
that he's a guy that it's gonna go get
it when if it's anybody else it's gonna
be an incompletion and Jo burrows not
gonna be the number one overall pick in
the draft hey III you know listen again
I take that into account you know yes
that's some of the argument I made with
to it to the thing that's different
there with Jo borough though is I saw so
many plays where guys aren't open or
it's not good pass protection and he
still makes a phenomenal play you know
to advance the LSU offense but you know
I think this guy is a hell of a player
Mike and I'll say this too you know when
my quarterback rankings came out I had a
lot of people that texted me to go man
Chris shut up about Justin Jefferson you
know you're shining too much light on
them so when I get those type of sets do
that tells me that people are laying in
the weeds about the football player and
I think he is a special special football
player you know he's been around in his
whole life you know but yeah I just I
look at him and go there's really no
weakness to his football game
sorry Kyle Justin Jefferson won't be
there at number 31 Chris is ruined all
right Henry rugs the third from Alabama
he was the fastest receiver at the
combine fastest player one of the
fastest players in the draft what
separates him from other guys who were
really really fast but maybe weren't as
good as they could have been in the NFL
like a John Ross or a marquise Goodwin
yeah well I think he plays a little
bigger and stronger than both of those
two guys right and you know even though
those guys are you know very fast
there's no doubt about it this guy's
right on right on the same level
certainly good route runner really tough
can break tackles with the ball in his
hands but yes to that point Mike I mean
that's the kind of player he is in
theory you're hoping he turns out to be
a Tyree kill type of guy now he's not as
muscular and powerful as Tyree kill but
I think he can be in a year or two as he
continues to grow into being a man at
this point but it's all the things he
can do for your football team Mike you
know it's no longer the day and age of
where
you need the prototypical Jerry Rice you
know wide receiver for your offense no
wood the way offenses are moving guys
around the motions the speed sweeps the
wide receiver screens
you know the play-action passes Henry
rugs the kick returns the punt returns
it's all of those things he can do for
your football team and as you know
everybody's looking for a player who can
make explosive plays that's the value of
tyree kill he's the greatest weapon in
the sport and that's why I would say
he's arguably one of the top two or
three receivers in the sport not
necessarily because he's like the most
refined route runner ever no he's not
even in the top five or ten as far as
route running goes but he's dangerous as
hell and you asked some DBS and football
how to cover them they go I just back
off and don't let him go behind me rugs
is that type of guy Mike you know think
about that guy you got two tight ends
two running backs it's second and two
alright and now there's one receiver
split out it's Henry rugs you go oh okay
what do you want to do you want to leave
him one-on-one outside or do you want to
put a safety back there but now your
compromise is stopping the run right so
it's the value of this type of player
that's still instills fear in a defense
and changes schemes let alone all the
talents he can bring to your offense in
special teams with the right quarterback
forces you to defend to defend the
entire field like Tina exactly my face
Patrick mahomes and Tyree kill because
that guy gonna get behind you
quick
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports